[Music]
wake up early in the morning press play
and let's get it in cause we rocking
with the fighter
[Music]
white guy in a room only white guy you
got a black community an asian community
more asians than anything in here i'm
just privileged [ __ ]
so sick of it sick of this [ __ ]
i'm taking this [ __ ] like that that's
why i came on this show
do you hate white people or something uh
no
no you know what what's weird is i think
people think this is like calculated
that cat you know
cat's hair and chin's hair and you guys
are here david's hair it's literally
it's the funniest people i know i don't
it could be all white if you're the
funniest i don't give a [ __ ] what
richard
as long as you're funny and cool sounds
like that i don't care what it is
exactly what racist would say
i don't care people like oh he just has
two black guys on because woke i'm like
no
these are the funniest guys that know
thank you are you are you just white
uh my mom born and raised in england
super white and my dad's german italian
oh [ __ ] i thought i know i thought you
were like
yeah oh really who i was like racially
ambiguous yeah i know
yeah yeah who was it oh uh chrissy d was
like you're not border
at all you have no board
yeah you're not bored at all like uh
like the hawaiian samoan might be white
people mix
yeah you know what i mean that'd be cool
like if you were at an asian rally i
don't think anybody would battle
i'm down
but you're not small dude like koreans
are pretty big man like chin's [ __ ]
to come in with tumble koreans yeah
you're a lot taller than i would expect
it too really
yeah i just saw one of your vlogs
yesterday what when you're eating like
supermarket sushi
dude that's dope thank you
ralph sushi is actually good they have
good sushi yeah right
and whole foods whole foods is pretty i
would imagine whole foods but ralph's i
like both
though what's that what are you eating
supermarket sushi for though
yes don't don't don't make this look
like you've never made it enough
you're gonna eat nobu every day it's
kind of
he's like i'm doing fine man i actually
chose this
this is the sweatshop and they corner
happened to be asian man shout out
well shout out to chin's vlogs jimmy
vlogging
yeah yeah it's a lot of work chappie
only fans in chinese
vlogging's [ __ ] hard isn't it yeah i
thought it was to be sort of easy but no
it's what's the
worst process because you're covering
like so much filming a bunch of stuff
throughout the day
and especially if you're like right now
feeling myself hooking everything up
that's just a
that's a beast and then and then don't
go to dinner with it because
yo so that that etiquette thing it got
really weird when vlogs got really
popular right
so before you would just be kicking it
with friends just chilling
nowadays like you're you don't know
what's going to happen like somebody's
either recording you on a story
no matter what you say somebody's going
to grab it it was a point too where a
group of my friends like we would say
some funny [ __ ] they're like hold up
don't finish the joke yet and they would
whip out their camera and i'm like hey
don't do that
like we're chilling yeah you just ruined
the [ __ ] moment like if you record it
you record it but it could happen
i mean look at morgan wallin who got
sort of canceled the fans let him get
canceled he's had the number one album
for like
[ __ ] eight months now but you know he
he
he [ __ ] up and said the n word we was
drunk with his buddies but the neighbor
was filming he had no [ __ ] clue
this neighbor uploads that to [ __ ]
social media than dudes camp i almost
got canceled yesterday actually wow
yeah so well they're hot right let's
hear it i mean they were trying you mean
asians are hot right now yeah well it
was because so
back in the day when you know vine was
popping i did a video with uh andrew
batchelor king batch
right got it and so we were doing this
play on words so when i grew up so
my my best friend gabo my parents on the
beauty supply store
so uh he was coming through to get some
products and we were just chopping it up
so in korean there's a word that's
higa which is you hold on now
cat told me this so it's like nega means
you so you and so he made a joke back
and he goes what'd your mom say and you
know i thought that was really funny
so we turned into a vine and uh people
didn't know or they
they should have known by context that
the word means you and korean so we made
a vine on that and then somebody tried
to cancel me saying i'm just frivolously
using the end
oh wow and i'm like no the joke is it's
a korean word
and it sounds like that and so that's
like jonathan
the intention is a [ __ ] joke but how
weird is it someone went out of their
way
to go through that video like oh david's
doing this
and then let's upload this like that's
your life dude and we we've
i've talked about this a lot because
like i uh so i grew up in sacramento
california right my parents own a black
beauty supply store my best friend's
black
majority of the community that grew up
is black so i think a lot of young kids
don't understand like the world that you
grew up in in the world that we grew up
in is different
that word and the meaning has changed
consistently correct right so
like the n-word right so when it first
started off like i remember when i was a
kid
the older generation above us hated the
word like it was a terrible thing to say
no matter who was saying and then when
it shifted
people started putting power into it and
made it into slang and still the older
older generation hated it a lot yeah and
so when i used it i remember because i
grew up in that neighborhood
specifically and i still remember the
time
when one of the og's in the neighborhood
taught me the word and it was a weird
weird experience yeah
so in uh sacramento at my parents store
on the weekends there was always a block
party
thursday fridays and saturdays most food
truck would come out yeah block party
people were shooting dice like they
would literally put up a cardboard
that's something
all my parents right i know right you
know respectfully they would do it too
because they didn't want to hit the
glass
so they would put up the cardboard and
they would roll dice and that was the
neighborhood that i grew up in
and so like i remember when i was a kid
og
on the block looked at me and he was
super nice to me right just because
i don't know what it was like he was
just really nice to all the kids in the
neighborhood and he was like hey what do
you call me
i'm like i don't know i don't know your
name he said you say i'm your
i'm like oh okay and ever since then
like i kept using the word over and over
and it was like a community thing yeah
well when i went to college
that that script changed a lot school i
went to ucr
okay uh okay and i didn't know outside
of northern california
how different that ward is like
bay area everybody used it la is a
little different i didn't know
so when uh like i got called out on it
i'm like oh is that is that an issue
and they're like yeah like we don't do
that over here i'm like okay cool and i
just dropped that i just stopped using
it
it was pretty simple you know it's like
this is how we feel about i'm like all
right yeah
i just moved on [ __ ] i was at a mic last
night i don't got to a fight with a guy
bro because he
he kept saying it was a white guy on
stage no yeah they do
all they do no
that's an open mic thing they do it at
the store they ain't doing that
i'm telling you but like i know because
that [ __ ] wouldn't fly at all yeah open
mics dudes are literally
white guys what white guy he tried to
say slick he was like he kept saying
vinegar
no no he said kept saying vinegar but he
was like yo man these vinegars
oh really yeah bro cause he's like i'm
not saying it i'm not saying it
the guy the guy that was at my show or
my open mic i was doing
he was like he dropped it like seven
times in the set
yeah but yeah i'm sure it puts the crowd
on their heels
yeah because no one's cool and i'm the
only black dude in the room so
everybody's looking at it yeah
they was like do something like hey man
are you gonna do something
yeah yeah exactly like hey man we can't
say anything do something
the audience was like so woke so they
were like speaking for me they're like
yeah
you know you really shouldn't do that
you know like they were just as i was
laughing i didn't even get to talk to
the dude
how do you think it makes him feel like
look at that girl
like go over there they're trying to
show me that they were an ally yeah it's
weird yeah that's the weirdest [ __ ]
you guys get weirded out by that [ __ ]
like when it kind of when the pendulum
swings a little too hard where they're
trying to show
kind of like the support and access it's
almost like virtue signaling right
oh it like drives me like they want to
make sure everyone knows
everybody just made all those videos
like when oh [ __ ] broke out i'm like
what the [ __ ]
yeah it's weird why are you making this
like i had a because of all the asian
[ __ ] popping off
i had dinner with a friend and then we
were eating at one of my favorite spots
called yang chaos
and we were eating and he was like is it
okay if i use a fork
because we were in a chinese spot and i
looked at this [ __ ] i'm like i
don't give a [ __ ]
eat your [ __ ] food talking about bro
he's like
are you gonna be offended if i don't use
these chopsticks
why are you yeah me for permission just
eat your [ __ ] food yeah like what are
you talking about yeah i hate that [ __ ]
it's just a little it makes me feel
weird you know like i can't yeah
that makes me feel weird yeah it's you
know other [ __ ] like conversation
over conversation where it's like you
know it's like hey just chill
like yeah like you if because because it
almost like sounds like they're
guilty yeah you know like they've like
like oh i've
seen this thing so now they're trying to
like make it
correct over correct over correct for
the [ __ ]
that's i don't know what they did but
they probably did something to where
they're [ __ ] just
overly yeah i've gotten dms and emails
from people like oh i think it's
it's so great that you bring black guys
on the road with yeah
no you don't understand i'm just doing
it because they're my friends
and they're funny i'm not like trying to
make this right my son
don't take me on the road if you stop
black white asian you ain't coming man
whether it's now or 1999 yeah
with with uh asia i'm sure you've talked
about it on your shows with the
with the asian the parlor stuff like
that yeah here's my take on this tell me
if i'm way off on this it's similar to
the
shooting the the active shooter that
happened the mass shooting that happened
in
uh boulder colorado you know though so
those were all white people
that got shot ten ten basically the
majority are white right
that's a white er that's where i went to
school i went to that grocery store
that's my grocery store where it
happened at
so that that's where i went to school
that's predominantly white neighborhood
super white boulder colorado super
hippie white so those ten people that
died
if if a shooter's to go there he's going
to
most likely shoot white people when it
comes to the mass shooting in the asian
community that dude had a sexual
attraction
to asians decided to shoot up asian
parlors
yeah and it be i i don't see and tell me
if i'm off on this
i don't find that as a hate crime i
think that's what he was into
he was upset that whatever they would
give him happy endings but they happen
to be the majority that run those type
of massage parlors i think i think the
am i off on that i think like the the
weird thing about that is
how people kind of paint racism right i
think that when we when we paint racism
we think that it's
the kkk person with the white hood on
saying racial epithet saying [ __ ] black
people [ __ ] asian people right but
this guy had a i think when people talk
about raising when it comes to the asian
culture it's the lack of respect right
especially how like asian women are
thought of massage parlor women
uh and it's a very possessive thing for
him to think that hey
these women don't like me so my
objective is to just [ __ ] kill them
because you make me feel a certain way
right
got it so that's where that racism comes
in it's still race motivated it's not
is that race motivate though because he
those women make him feel a certain type
of way
all women do right because he was going
to those massage parlors
because if he would have went to strip
clubs
but he wasn't going to strip clubs well
that's what i'm saying yeah that was
his thing he was infatuated with the
asian culture of those massage parlors
yeah because it has a predominantly
asian rant i i understand that that
perspective where
it's i think it's skewing towards a it's
more of a sexual is it
is it a woman's thing or is it you know
what i'm saying it's both
right it's it's both it's the identity
of like the type [ __ ]
asian woman thing it's his fetish of it
so i think that fetishization is the
part where people think it's it's racial
right and i understand that stuff too
right
so you can't just delete that that part
of it and just say that it's a sexual
thing
because it's offensive to the community
and on top of that too uh media outlets
said that he was saying racial epithets
while he was looking for asian people i
didn't know that yeah so that was
that would make it a hate crime yeah so
that that was the part that wasn't
reported either
and so you know that situation just
really sucks too and i think like the
problem that a lot of asian americans
are having is the fact that
when we say that we have a problem
people go shut the [ __ ] up
you know it's not that big of a deal we
got other stuff over here but it's like
hold on a second i think
i think people not me but i think cult
society goes shut the [ __ ] up because
you guys are so successful
where with other communities and uh
minorities aren't as successful so it's
like
you guys are you guys are good yeah
that's what they're doing and the
problem with that too is just like what
about just the fact that people died
you know you kind of take the humanity
away from a culture right so it's like
well you have all these great things
going for you so shut the [ __ ] up that's
why i even have a problem with two like
where the over
when people over correct uh their you
know racial biases right
so for example it's like is every white
person that i meet now
inherently racist just because this is
what's skewing towards media
and do you have to over correct and
apologize for just being white no you
don't have to do
if you're not racist you don't if you're
not racist you're not you don't need to
do it you're good
you know what you're doing now there's
this narrative of like
a lot of uh white people have to
constantly apologize to us which is
weird like i don't understand that
my thing is just be a good person yeah
if you if you recognize
this history that this country has with
racism and slavery
that's pretty much all you have to do
when you deny it that's when people have
a problem correct yeah when you deny it
like institutionalized racism it's just
kind of like yo
just give me that at least right yeah
it's like the whole michael shea
stand-up bit he goes
people have a problem with the phrase
black lives matter
just matters not matters more not
matters less just yeah
yeah so that's all you have to do and
it's a pretty simple song yeah i i think
with that with that boulder shooting too
and it breaks my heart because
i listen to breakfast club every morning
it's one of my favorite shows and
charlemagne and dj envy
and angela yee you know when she
reported it the first thing charlemagne
goes let me guess white guy
white guy and then dj amigos yeah he
looks white and they're like oh i bet if
it's a black guy they would have shot
him what they tape and i'm like oh this
is a race thing
what about the 10 people that died also
it's not a white guy you [ __ ] idiot
yeah he's from syria he's not a wife
he's not
what about the 10 people that died dude
why is this turned into race thing
yeah that's the hard part yeah that's
the agenda they're like trying to drive
down our throats now everything is race
it's that gets a lot of attention yeah
you say racially motivated well
there's been seven mass shootings in the
past 10 days yeah in atlanta in atlanta
well do you know how many were white
in atlanta or no in general how those
out of those seven
how many i think there was two but the
the media is like white guys mass
shooters white guy master white guy
that's just not the agenda but that's
the agenda they want to go to yeah it's
kind of weird too
specifically because a lot of the the
attacks on asian people a lot of black
americans have been highlighted right
and so there's been a bit of a tension
here yeah yeah
with the blacks and asians yeah and like
the the
the problem that i've always had with
that too is just it's not
it's not just because specific
individuals did something it doesn't
represent the whole culture right
and my my biggest thing with that was
like it's it's never been an asian
person
kind of battling the idea of like a
black american or a white american
attacking us it's just
i feel like it's asian americans versus
uh the concept of what americans think
about asians
americans in general right very quiet
passive you're not going to do [ __ ]
which happens a lot this is there's a
reason
why a lot of these elder agents are
attacked is because we don't report
crimes yeah
we're they're afraid of causing trouble
they don't want to cause trouble
they also don't speak the language so a
lot of these crimes trying to just go
under the radar because they know they
won't report it
during chinese new year we walk around
with cash because we give out red
envelopes
[ __ ] know that [ __ ] they rob
them they beat them but they don't
report it yeah so now we're trying to
change the narrative where in this
country passivism is seen as a weakness
correct it's not like that in asian
culture when you don't say [ __ ] to
people
it's not even just polite you're [ __ ]
beneath me where the [ __ ] would i talk
to you oh interesting so it's a sign of
strength
i'm not going to converse with somebody
that isn't on my life
i can't give them energy yeah you're not
we're not going to do that that is a
philosophical belief it doesn't work
like that in this country though
you have to be loud you have to say [ __ ]
just to make changes so now we're
starting to understand that system is
like oh we actually do have to speak up
so the generation before us brought
these confucius and philosophical ideals
that doesn't work in this country so
that's why this youth now
they're speaking up we're doing rallies
and now people like oh [ __ ] when you die
it hurts you
you know like yeah yeah i didn't know
you guys aren't cool with this
it's like no [ __ ] yeah yeah so now you
know i'm learning this stuff now too
because like for me
i took that advice from my dad so like
for example we owned a black beauty
supply store right
ninety-eight percent of the customers
are great people two percent were
[ __ ]
so i've learned from my father because
he's also a pastor just to treat people
on equal grounds he's like you can't
you can't give these two percent people
that type of energy
because you're going to let your ideals
and how you feel about that two percent
spread to the other 90s smart man
right so i wish people would understand
that as well too
with everything though even political
like the left and the right like
i [ __ ] with a lot of people on the right
i [ __ ] with people on the left but it's
the outliers that are so loud
where if you're like oh i vote for trump
like oh you're like the guys that
stormed the capital
no i don't [ __ ] with them at all man
those people are [ __ ] crazy or if
you're
far far right oh you're uh whatever is
proud where where the [ __ ] they're
uh extremists are like oh you're
probably no not at all people just need
to give the right amount of [ __ ]
exactly it's too much [ __ ] to give
right now like give the right amount of
[ __ ]
and i i think like i always had a big
issue specifically when trump was in um
was the president was because people
were allowing themselves to destroy
their personal relationships with people
over a president correct yeah that was
the biggest [ __ ] deleted the history the
great relationship you would have with
the friend over politics over politics
it's like well
you can also look at the individual and
see those personal interactions and
you're saying i'm going to throw all
that away correct
[ __ ] all that [ __ ] [ __ ] all the good
times that we had all the great things
you've done
this personal relationship that we've
built over years [ __ ] that because you
said that you voted for a certain party
you did it strange i was like
you're a [ __ ] dumbass yeah yeah
you're you're putting too much energy
into that about a person who didn't give
a flying [ __ ] about you and you have no
control over
like trump's gonna trump biden's gonna
bite in you're not you're not gonna do
[ __ ]
yeah it is you're gonna ride and die for
that guy yo 2020 was weird man
it was [ __ ] weird it was all 20 21's
coming hot too though
i can't wait for 2021 i'm like yeah no
no 2020 was so
tough for your boys 21 is coming in hot
let's take a little break from chatting
with
my boy david so
because i'm here to talk to you about
rev town jeans the best jeans the only
genes listen
you boys are out there you're like me
you're like oh i don't know what jeans
to wear i get these thick thighs and
this dumper for an
ass but i can't find jeans at work well
i got you covered baby we're talking
about rev
town all right rev town they partnered
up with this old school denim designer
milan italy
to create jeans that look and fit
amazing it's you're going to think
you're wearing
some sweats or yoga pants with actually
some fly ass jeans
no wonder the fast grown denim brand for
men and
the women's i don't like mins in them
all
at 79 bucks a pair they're less than
half the price of some of the so-called
designer jeans that we've been trying on
for years so
get rid of that pick up a pair of rev
town jeans go to revtown.com
fighter that's r-e-v-t-o-w-n.com
fighter and they got something super
special for the fire kid listeners
all you got to do is head over to
revtown.com fighter to upgrade your
denim game today roughtown.com
fighter tell you what man i was riding
my bike the other day a car almost hit
me i went oh man
life is so fragile and i have a family i
got to worry about and thank god
that there's life insurance all right
you need life insurance because you
don't know when life
is going to take you out all right and
you got to protect the ones you love and
that's why i chose ladder ladder makes
it
super fast and easily covered you just
need a few minutes you got minutes
to save your family right if you pass
away unexpectedly a phone or a laptop
you got that we got just
we got you covered man ladder smart
algorithm works
in real time so you find out instantly
if you're approved no hidden fees you
can cancel any time
and since life insurance costs more as
you age now is the time to cross it off
your list
so check out ladder today to see if
you're instantly approved go to
ladderlife.com fighter
that's l-a-d-d-e-r-life dot com slash
fighter
ladderlife.com fighter nobody to go back
to what you're saying like with people
like over
like or questioning like white people
questioning like damn am i
you know have i been racist or anything
like i was adopted to a
white family and even they were like
hitting me up like dude
i mean what have i done i'm like
you took a black kid
for you i'm sorry we're sorry we didn't
sign you up for basketball
well that's racist well that's right
yeah this calls racism
so you were adopted huh yeah in my teens
and where are you from
i'm originally from arizona oh [ __ ]
shout out to mesa baby
well that like that's like phoenix area
how far from 30 minutes
from phoenix yeah no not and i it's i
mean everything's kind of like 20
minutes
in phoenix and everything's pretty easy
to get to i love it traffic's not like
crazy i'm surprised phoenix isn't
popping more like everybody's sucking
texas off or florida or nashville it's
like what about
then you can live in arizona but if you
[ __ ] when you're guys trash cans melt
when it's too hot oh yeah
there's no one really out there's no one
really because you would die
you would actually literally oh it's
interesting but that's how vegas is too
yeah but here's the thing i live in the
valley dog vegas and i know it's not dry
heat but
last summer dude it got to 124 the
hottest it's ever been
and i i walked outside i was riding my
bike i'm like god man i could jump
in that way come on dog 120 you jumping
rope yeah
i don't mind i like it [ __ ] well but
i mean i don't mind the heat but it it
gets
[ __ ] hot there you go you're right it
isn't you know it isn't as popular as
like
texas everyone's talking texas texas
texas boy about an airbnb in phoenix i
don't know
yeah yeah i mean have y'all been out to
minnesota
yeah i've done comments hold on you've
been there bro why are you saying it's
hot [ __ ]
coldish oh there you go oh yeah okay i
got it i think about the ride
when i did a stand-up show out there i
remember this kid that was showing me
around he's like you want to see
something really cool so he had like a
cup of cold water yeah he goes outside
he throws it in the end and just turns
in the snow yeah
i'm like get my ass back inside i can't
see the [ __ ] the [ __ ]
what's wrong with you i'd rather do
phoenix than like minnesota or like a
[ __ ] like a chicago winner
[ __ ] off dude oh yeah like when you
gotta scrape the ice off your car before
you get in it yeah that's working
yeah i'd rather take the heat than take
all day
any [ __ ] day that's what we get a lot
of people from like the midwest and like
the east coast that move out to arizona
though like you like
arizona there's a lot of uh bears fans
there a lot of uh
yeah a lot of they have their bars and
[ __ ] yeah they have all dude i would
move to phoenix just for
jt wings this weekend
are you going there this weekend what
are you doing
[Music]
it's like a bar but they have these
wings tell them they put you on game
tell them
they put it in arizona dude yeah you
could tell this [ __ ]
[Music]
he fixed his posture and everything is
like
take them out dump sauce on them grill
them it's like this special barbecue
teriyaki hot sauce
look at that they're like they're like
they're like burnt a little bit oh the
best way
what's the right kind of it's the best
wings i've ever had in my life with this
i'm not
eating it right now but i would [ __ ]
break my dice we smashed out like 80.
but we have no no you understand we have
50 in each box we have five boxes you
ate 50 wings listen
let me just but it was there's like six
dudes it's real cops yes
it was a big [ __ ] face
there's a lot of dude a bunch of dudes
licking their fingers
not even using the hand wipers
arizona uh no no no the place is too hot
for me
no you gotta go all right i've never
heard anybody
you got to go there what are we in march
it's good right now that's where you
know what place is trash
it's good right now but like june it
gets popping
bro i'll tell you when that june [ __ ]
comes around
it's a bad time to do father's day it
hits it's a bad time to do comedy there
too oh worst time summer's the worst
because we did it yeah we did it yeah we
did not get time to do comedy we did it
we was people that don't want to go out
we were too lit
that's right it was jupiter i think
that's where we got covet
you think it's definitely where we go
okay you got so much [ __ ] when you [ __ ]
i'm not gonna lie i jumped on that
bandwagon so i was like
i was like [ __ ] brendan's shot
and then i caught it i was like hey i
kind of jumped the gun real fast
i was like oh [ __ ] i liked all the
comments like oh that's what you get
like [ __ ] i'm fine did you get any like
crazy sympathy nothing i was biking 30
miles a day
yeah it's called being healthy that's
how you beat covington wait did you you
had some crazy symptoms well i had uh
i mean it wasn't crazy i guess because i
had like the the lower back pain the hip
pain oh god i got it which i didn't
expect i didn't know that was a symptom
until like after your body i got the uh
i got the [ __ ]
headache the head yeah i did get the
headache right here but i powered
through it that [ __ ]
[ __ ] me so when i i felt a little
funky on a saturday right got it and i
was like i i feel like something's a
little off like my energy level's off
and i'm like okay let me just
take this covet test i took a covettest
turns out that i had it but i was like
it could be a false negative just in
case let me check into this hotel and
affect other people
just be careful
they have a protocol and everything i
possibly could and they're like i think
they just need the business they're like
we're going to lock you in there and
nobody's going to come to your room so
they allowed me to stay there i was like
cool oh [ __ ] so i went in there i'm not
sure if that was legal but they let me
so legit
i was there and then uh i was like i
still feel relatively good
and so i'm in a hotel for a week away
from my lady there's a couple things i'm
gonna do order in a jack-off that's it
yeah wait wait and you did it just to
quarantine yourself yeah because i don't
want her to get sick
so i got it all right cool so i i went
to the hotel room and then i ordered uh
wings lemon pepper wings from a fat
burger and i got a huge [ __ ] fat
burger
i get there i drink the soda i'm like ah
they didn't put enough syrup in this
[ __ ] it's not that good
oh you can't taste it i i bit into a
wing and then i was like
oh it's not too bad whatever i dip it
into uh
the ranch bite take a second bite no
taste
and i cried like i'm not i'm not even
lying i [ __ ] i actually tell you what is
it
you know you know what you know how i
know i'm fat is evil i lost my taste
and then i would still eat pizza and
burritos even though i couldn't taste
them and i had
sickness i've done so much hot sauce on
just so i could feel
something the sensation i still you'd
get a little sensation so
you're just chewing you're just eating
to eat like there's you're just eating
to live that's at that point like you
literally can't taste anything so i
started
you know i was freaking out a bit
because i was happy i was going to be
away from my lady for 10 days
and then i could just jack off and eat
you took half my pleasure away yeah so
now and you can only jack off so much
it's like the first day you're done
you're just sitting there how old are
you
33
[Applause]
we're gonna get food on my jacket then
there's no
schedule later yeah my jacket now i'll
be too tired for the show i don't know
it was like two and then i was like i'm
i'm good yeah yeah yeah
yeah i'm pretty good and i couldn't eat
any food i actually lost 10 pounds
within those uh 10 days i was in there
damn because i just ate the same [ __ ]
soup dim sum and salad
how long were you feeling it uh i had
brain fog for about
almost three months three months fog
yeah
so i i i didn't know if he was brain fog
you just think maybe i'm stupid
i didn't say that no they say that's
what masturbation does to you though oh
really
oh [ __ ]
that was the weird thing like i i
couldn't it was kind of frustrating
because i couldn't keep my thoughts
together
yeah you're doing a podcast it was the
worst and so
uh i i was on uh listening to rogan's
podcast and
he gave out a cocktail he brought
somebody on he got gave out a cocktail
to help you like antibiotics don't
listen to romeo man but let me tell you
like uh elk meat and then he'll be like
what you need to do
get two pounds of elk meat even the
doctor's like what he's like
and then stay in the sauna make sure
it's 220 degrees
what bro science is this i don't know if
it's like a placebo effect but i started
taking the
the zinc and quercetin combo oh i
started feeling a little better it might
have been a placebo effect i don't know
no i'm sure it's real
he got that from doctor like i make fun
of him but he got from some doctor for
sure did you do the vitamin d
stuff too yeah i did it after which
didn't matter at that point i know right
now yeah see i i did the drip the
vitamin d
drip everything it's like uh iv filled
with vitamin d and vitamins just drips
they come to the crib
yeah you got that money money that's
rich people i know right
about right now [ __ ]
i'm sorry i thought we're on the same
level you're like in four seasons
how long have you been in los angeles uh
nine years now
he's in pasadena yeah i was in k-town
for about six years which was really fun
dude i went to k-town really for the
first time with chin and kat
for uh korean bbq where do we eat that
quarter quarters
is like one of those like first original
spots of the wings there's a lot of
other spots though i love those things
this is the spot we went to gucci
america i want to go to that dean it was
not american oh i got racially profiled
there was fantastic
because i got up yeah it was great
i heard him talking [ __ ] about that i
was like hell yeah
because i get to go the bathroom and
there's this uh like asian table and
they have like some bad [ __ ] around
and i see all them stop and they look
and they guys like man there's a [ __ ]
a lot of white people
in there i was like oh hell yeah he's
like yeah
[ __ ] that he pulled his eyes back in
there i'm one of you guys
la is opening it's so funny like when i
hear you call him chin i think you're
like racially attacking him [ __ ]
i know right now that's his name it's
not even a korean name too i know i
changed it to chin
what was your real name jin jin oh jim
yeah jin
dude like i know i was wrong when i was
younger because i grew up in texas
my friends couldn't say gin they said
yeah
i was like
[Applause]
it's a great show did you think that was
his american name
what david yeah yeah and he had like a
korean i had a crew i was like yeah
cat what did i or you you were there too
jim what did i eat on king this thing
this week
uh do you know oh guido oh yeah yeah
would you like that but
you did it properly they didn't eat it
like straight dick style yeah no i knew
that like i was like oh this can go
super viral if i'm like deep throwing
this clam
so that's so i'm gonna put it to the
side
and like bite into it on the side yeah
dude i threw up
right away and it was raw no no no no no
no no what is it
you didn't eat it right
very large molex that looks like a dick
it looks like a big
purple dick and i i got the idea for it
because there's all those
youtube asian girls who are making
videos of it and they're like
deep down the thing basically like that
holding that thing right there good see
but that
see that that it got a little cold so he
went
you look like you own like 10 pizza
shops
my hair is super greasy though yeah but
that that thing was
that thing was thick and chunky and
you'll see
i think we'll post it today so i buy it
from the side it squirts everywhere oh
yeah i started throwing up
everywhere crisp he was slapping and
making a squirt
oh yeah i was slapping well that's why i
saw the girls doing the video so i was
like hi
hey girls and yo you never seen the
videos though
yeah they like that it's like there's
like a girl in china that dipped it in
chili oil
and it was [ __ ] disgusting that's why
i was like can i get some soy
soy sauce i put soy sauce on it i threw
up everywhere chris
deep throats that thing and as he's
eating at least
it shoots down his throat and he's all
it's pretty funny yeah yeah it drops
tomorrow
like i couldn't be on fear fact i i do
well in the athletic activities
these asian people killed a fearful i
know it was easy
this is not even a joke like when my mom
watched an episode of fear factor they
were eating uh
tripe and which is a tribe is the the
lining of the cow stomach it's
honeycombed
it's white it looks it's i hate it too a
lot of asian people love it it looks
gross to me and i don't even like the
taste but
i've had it before it's like yeah
chinese yeah yeah
i love i love asian people love this
[ __ ] that's how it isn't watching i'm
sure be like i could
dominate no my mom was looking at the
episode right she goes so what's the
cooking show you're watching
that's not a joke that's fast what
cooking show are you watching
my word you're a mom they're eating
horse dick this
is not so sometimes they fry it it was
rattle right it does look like a
honeycomb though yeah yeah so it's the
inner lining of the cow's stomach it's
it's
weird how's a little salty chewy it
tastes like
guts you know like cow guts you know you
had like
it's it's not like so old fall like you
know like the cow innards and stuff yeah
it's not really as stinky as that
because you have to clean it really well
but after you boil it and you put it in
sauce it kind of takes the flavor
everything so it goes away but it's
really chewy i don't like the texture
almost like you got almond milk the
texture is kind of way chewier than that
oh
really so you gotta you gotta chomp on
that [ __ ] you eat that [ __ ] too
yeah so it is chewy in the beginning but
then it breaks down pretty fast it's i
think it's delicious yeah a lot a lot of
people like it i just do they fry it
i mean they're i'm sure they make it
friday whatever you want oh you can do
whatever
it's done in a brand did you take those
gold gio ducks after the show yesterday
yes you took them home we'll just say
yesterday's not expensive bro
90 bucks i know it's nine bucks pricey
[ __ ] what is that that's iv drip status
that's what we were just talking about
and
[Applause]
oh [ __ ] as soon as i got it i started
slapping i know yeah
that [ __ ] started nothing and it like
dripped that was great
oh [ __ ] it really does though okay so
there's a better one right with the
spices and stuff yeah we're just
watching
it like the chili sauce i think i
remember this something like this though
did we show you that there you go oh she
goes yeah
she's getting saucy nuts oh no
oh [ __ ] oh [ __ ] no we're not doing that
see i didn't do that oh
i did it on the side i took a little
trunk out of it and i threw up
everywhere so
the origin the origin of this clam is is
china that's a cloud
no it's actually not china it's actually
canada it's canada
so it's pissing right now right well i
don't know what he's doing there's a lot
of fluid in there
so what they'll actually do when they
when they prepare it they'll uh par
boil it and they actually skin that
stuff on the outside oh god
like it's foreskin skin it down and then
they'll slice it real thin they'll do
like a hot oil with soy sauce and garlic
and ginger
and that's like my favorite and it's
probably pretty good yeah no it just
tastes the way i ate
a really good disgusting yeah well yeah
you need to wash that thing off yeah
they got it in like the water it came in
from the supermarket
and they're like oh here take a bite you
really don't give a [ __ ] about cover do
you that's cool
i know i didn't give a [ __ ] about that
bro
that's what i said i said did you buy
this around bats where'd
this come from and i bit the [ __ ] out of
that thing
threw up everywhere i threw up
everywhere yeah it was it was pretty
gross
it was you ate it hey hold on he's
allergic to shellfish i wanted him to
we got him one to eat but then that's
what i'm driving like ah
[ __ ] chappelle's allergic to shellfish
and then chris had to shoot all day
and he's like man i don't know if i
should eat this thing because i don't
want to smell like [ __ ] all day
he was scared he was going to check my
girl what is this
like [ __ ] these clams the real song
one girl's gonna be mad she'll be
questioning
i was like just show her this video
y'all won't eat like weird [ __ ] outside
of what you normally i can't
know the dices i'll get is uh grilled
eel on sushi damn that's that's the
christmas
i do i'll throw up i just i don't i
can't do it really i'll throw if you had
octopus
i eat everything you've had octopus i've
had live octopus
no the little ones were like your lips
wait wait man octopus are cool
bro why would you do that though it's a
cultural thing dude it really
did it yeah
you cut me off the heater i [ __ ] know
so like he's like there's a war
korean's an octopus man we can't stand
octopus
you don't like history
but it's like this weird thing so like
if uh it got really popular
popularized in korean uh fish markets
out there and so they'll take like these
baby octopus
and so when you cut the tentacles they
still ride and they they wiggle
wiggle wiggle so they'll you literally
eat it as the tentacles are moving and
you can feel the suction cups in your
mouth if you don't chew it correctly
you'll choke and die
so why why take that risk i don't know
korean people are weird so you have to
really make
to that [ __ ] you haven't seen a
poor one they like did octopus
what the [ __ ] is that different sauce
yeah chin wants to do what kind of sauce
they put in uh so sesame oil
and salt and pepper is like the typical
i love octopus because
doesn't that kind of like uh it doesn't
taste like anything though
yes have you had uh chin showed me the
the raw the wrong thing is
you've had it yeah boom chin i want to
try it so it's delicious right
so like the reason why uh chicken can't
be consumed like that here in the states
is how they raise the chicken
okay so the way they raised in japan i
don't know what the [ __ ] it is but they
don't do it like how they do this treat
them right so you could have it medium
rare
and the texture's weird like it doesn't
i don't understand the appeal of it per
se
but once you have it in the sauces and
everything else is good damn you've had
it all can i yeah you had it all i just
asked a question
so um you said raw chicken yeah so it's
like
you ate that like how we cook it you put
it so it was like slightly seared on a
on a yakitori
grill with like uh binchotan um
yeah you could have it like sashimi too
and then they slightly seared it so it
was almost like tuna would they sear it
on the outside and it was wrong
[Applause]
clean this [ __ ] throw it yes but okay
you're good he's good she's good he's
good
we all go you might get it no no no i do
the sauna i do elk meat
damn damn so what have you ate like i
mean i'll try
anything really uh if i don't like it i
just won't eat it have you had puffer
fish
uh yes that's it's pretty good it's
weird like what is that pokemon
no it's a mad race
dude at least he's not overcompensated
you know
like alex racist man oh that's like
pokemon hell yeah
oh you like a pokemon we're like
you see brendan i feel uncomfortable
i'm the only one canceled here you know
i don't know
i'm the only one a white guy
you're firing off these cancer questions
hey man we played street fighters uh
chuckling your favorite
i'm just footballing my ideas today i'm
like please don't
are you gonna watch the new motor
comment actually yes
i'm all right for that bro i can't wait
i'm gonna let my five-year-old watch it
because i got a melody i got him more
mortal kombat on his nintendo basically
got it for me but he'll watch me play
and then he solved the trailer for the
movies like dad that's scorpion like
that's papa's favorite character
and now the movie's outside the place
probably you can't oh [ __ ] yeah yeah
that's
good i think the movie is rated r this
time yes
the first one has the first one the
first one wasn't bad no not bad
wait wait the second one or the first
one the first one first one
wait what's the it's two it's two first
ones it's mortal kombat and there's two
first ones
yeah literally impossible because they
had different than different cats
because it was split and there was a
second movie which would be the second
that'd be number two
i think there's only one uh main mortal
kombat
it was like it was like mid 90s yeah
that one that one because the second one
was the
with the dude that's an annihilation
guru uh
yeah he was in the gorillas so the very
first one
i know i'm not tripping yeah oh no i
know my motorcar the first one
the first thing the first one's 1995.
the second one is 1997. see that'd be
we call that the second one malik so
there's one
in 1995 then the second one killed in
1997. it says two so
yeah i think they have they've only done
two okay so let's see the third one this
new one's gonna be
five oh that [ __ ] looks like get over
here i'm glad they made it rated r
and something zero looks dope at zero
because he come in he drafted you right
like oh let me guess you like jack
i love jack with a big jack jack jack
metal arms i love jacks
i love jacks i love you like sonia sonia
was dope she shoot
yeah i love that and i love sub zero
mm-hmm why are you looking at me
you don't like racing and i love reptile
and radio just happens to be the most
asian that's what i'm saying
mortal kombat on uh my son's nintendo
they have robocop on there they have the
joker now they have sylvester stallone
rambo who cares do you care about the
type of violence that your kids
are allowed to participate in when it
comes to games good question uh
not really because he knows it's fake
okay because he knows like
off the bat like he knows it's fake and
i was exposed to it as a young kid
i think it's good for him to know how
fake that is you know yeah yeah yeah
it's dicey i don't know how to feel
about that like me neither i grew up
with another side yeah i grew up with it
and i'm fine i don't have mental issues
you know but then you know that active
shooter was like i also played mortal
kombat
and the graphics are way so much better
that's a small percentage
correct wait wait smaller percentage
that gives i mean losers are going to
lose
do you guys all train fine because you i
mean obviously you're a ufc uh
heavyweight yeah you guys also trained
too
[ __ ] no all right i was a cheerleader
dog
that's when i was a boxer well you do
train fighting then yeah
but not mma though how long did you box
for uh
13 years god damn so my man got hands
okay yeah but again i mean again
you got a ufc fighter this is a great
dynamic you got the boxer right yeah
cool i also box though yeah
and i was undefeated yeah
i was about to give him a whole
compliment
that's crazy because like i started
training kickboxing about uh
two years ago right and to lose weight
or just to learn the well i was
i was big i was like 300 pounds oh [ __ ]
it was 300 pounds
yeah you guys should start a podcast
right
uh yes somewhere on my ig chin bring up
your big pick and then we look at
david's
first and then we'll see jenny craig
yeah
you got to go all the way down okay
there's like half naked pictures of me
too when i'm when i'm big
oh you just like are you a born after oh
i didn't give a [ __ ] he was confident
like whether you wear a shirt or not
people still know you're fat so it's
like all the way down yeah it was always
strange when the fat kids were the
the shirt in the pool i'm like dude you
know you just put a target
it's like you know you stick out more
fat yeah your titties are
everywhere dude but again it's like i
guess it's because they gotta sweat
i'm gonna go all the way down yeah it's
it's it's been like three years now so
okay it's been a hot second let the
[ __ ] wear a t-shirt in the pool
[ __ ] it yeah i know i'm just saying as
you know
how about when we're going to jump in
the lake and spokane like dog should we
wear shirts
[Laughter]
mark was like nah man i was like yeah
you're right
you're right you're right i don't know
the confidence y'all guys at where are
my [ __ ] half naked pictures at
it was a lot that's a lot of snow cones
there's a lot of food on there i think
we skipped a lot but i did
this was like the original weight loss
so that's his this is not even as big as
i got
i was even bigger than that and how much
did you weigh there this was like maybe
270. so i got 30 pounds heavier than
that wow damn
so so you legit hit 300. well i didn't
even know i was fat
what nobody told me you knew that yes
that enabled it yeah insane
my girl no you look good you're looking
like oh yeah
i saw that picture too yup that one
right there oh damn so you know you know
who actually got me to lose weight was
actually
a specific joe rogan podcast it was with
david goggins
to you yeah david goggins and there was
another one with uh dr rhonda patrick
okay and so listening to those podcasts
kind of pieced together
uh like i didn't realize how out of
shape i was because like health wasn't
an issue for me because when you're
younger it doesn't matter how fat you
are still playing ball i'm still doing
whatever
yeah you know i just had like a one inch
burp but it didn't really matter
but i i didn't realize how out of shape
i was and there was literally this
moment and it's just facts like
my my uh fiance and i went out to eat
and i'm i didn't know how big i was to
the point where i would sit there and
judge
fat people who are less fat than i would
preach you know what i mean this is my
life and so i was sitting here and i kid
you not this was the aha moment when we
went out to eat
there was a couple two fat fat people
but they're still not as fat as i am
yeah and i looked at them i was like
babe look at these [ __ ] fat people
and she looked at me she goes you're
fatter than them
i'm like what the [ __ ] [ __ ] you talking
like that
what you're talking about i had to joke
over with it
what do you mean she was like you're fat
in them i'm not fatter than them
and i was like no [ __ ] way and then i
went on the scale and i was like
yo this scale's busted you know i
thought the same thing so like i'm
always making these excuses
about how big i am and then um when to
play ball
yo this is actually [ __ ] funny like
yeah so i used to hoop a lot before i
[ __ ] up my knees and my ankles and
then
i literally tried to do a i tried to
cross somebody up the ball moved but my
body didn't
and i'm like oh you're a fat person damn
you can't even extend your fat [ __ ]
arm to grab the ball on the other side
yeah
and everything started like piecing
together and i'm like i'm really out of
shape i got a blood test i did this
whole body scan [ __ ]
and then you could really see the actual
numbers of how out of shape doctor's
like yeah you're fat man it's confirmed
so
whatever you want people we got to hear
it though yeah dude
i think fast shaming works but that but
that's not what but that fascinating to
get me was i was trying to shave my
my ball fro okay you know what i'm
saying man i had to lift up man
probably coach johnny before yeah
but it was tough and that's what did it
for me that's what [ __ ] me up yeah i
was like [ __ ] i can't even
i was like i've never had to do that i
couldn't like really and he speaks these
before and afters and this
brave bastard sent her to the group chat
and i was like
what that guy do baby
i'll tell you what else to get you in
shape is because we work at this gym
called zoo culture and
we're the ugliest bradley martin's yeah
today when he came in i went dude look
at these [ __ ] dude there was
these dudes like
it was pretty warm in there he and i are
fully clothed
i got a turtleneck and they were just
jacked i'm just shocked
i'm like do we have to work out dude
they were filming uh one of their
workout videos
and i like went by with a ball like hey
big [ __ ] get out of the way
you'll see me making a pants almost oh
god i apologize
hey dog you're in the way
[Laughter]
workout in a lot faster because
everybody's on their grind yes you know
that's why that's why so like when
people are you know they look like me
and [ __ ] they they feel like they can't
go
you should go to those gyms because you
can get your workout in a lot faster
people don't [ __ ] around in there
they're not on their [ __ ] phones no
they're ready to get their [ __ ] done
get the work in and get out it's like i
worked out with bradley martin yesterday
we both got there
we were chopping it up and he's like man
you wanna hit a workout real quick he's
like what you doing
i'm down for whatever man i was like oh
my shoulder's kind of [ __ ] if i want
to tell him
and then you know he's [ __ ] massive
he's i don't know if you ever see him
he's weird he doesn't look human he's
way bigger than me
one of the best dudes i've ever met me
and him we're like uh
[ __ ] uh you know he's great dude so
we're working out
and he grabs 120 pound dumbbells i'm
like what the [ __ ]
and then he's like here we should do a
quick eight yeah we haven't even got
them all yeah quick
here we go and then just because i felt
the pressure i'm doing it with him
yeah we got done i was like oh my
shoulder hurts so bad
he's like you good man i'm like oh dude
yeah did you see that video he posted
yesterday bro did you see that where are
you
i was i was with him yeah i saw more
dude he puts me on game on merch because
he's like dude your merch you post
stagnant [ __ ] and stuff like this and
he's like you're selling
we were comparing numbers he's like dude
you're selling this and your promotion
is shitty
he's like videos go such further he's
like like he did that a long time
the girls he did the girls uh he was
like i did that a long time ago and then
he's like this is what i'm gonna post
and look what the [ __ ] is wrong with you
bro watch this [ __ ] that's
455 pounds
[Music]
look at those guys he got good hands his
shoulders
he's in joggers by the way those are
gene joggers
megan the stallion knees damn when
you're that strong you don't even need
to know how to fight
you just got to be big and strong yeah
he was like dude he's like we gotta try
this thing um
but you could beat his ass though right
for real though yeah yeah yeah
i would never but yeah
i would never do that but yeah that's
the amazing thing about being a trained
fighter you have that confidence because
you know what you can do
you know let's take another break
because you're probably starving like me
and you're on a diet and you don't want
to go home and make a whole freaking
meal you don't know what to do i got you
covered cat's eating right now i'm
talking about freshly
freshly offered chef made nutrient
packed delicious meals delivered fresh
to your door
no cooking required how about that
grocery shopping and cooking can be a
pain especially right now you got to
wear a mask
there's lines depending what state
you're in so let freshly help you out
all right your meals arrive cooked and
fresh every freaking week so you can
keep your fridge
stocked and skip the trip to the store
save time
everybody's happy ordering is easy visit
freshly.com
choose from over 30 delicious satisfying
better for you meals all right
freshly can fit your lifestyle with a
variety of plans and meals to pick
that work for your dietary needs
preferences taste family size
you're on a diet vegan we got you
covered fam and now
you guys can try freshly for just six
dollars and sixteen cent per meal
think how much you spend when you eat
out think how much you spend when you
order online
this is the way to go and it's great
food stop searching for the internet for
healthy food near me
every night start living freshly your
meals are always delivered fresh never
frozen
ready to heat and enjoy in just three
minutes they're adding new meals every
week
we got you covered man right now freshly
is offering you guys
40 off your first two orders when you go
to freshly.com
fighter so stop stressing about dinner
let your thick
friend help you out here go to
freshlyfreshly.com
fighter for 40 off your first two orders
that's freshly.com
slash fighter for 40 off your first two
orders
i would never do that but yeah that's
the amazing thing about being a trained
fighter you have that confidence because
you know what you can do
you know and i think like when you know
when you're younger you would scrap with
anybody right
but there's a difference when when the
train fighter puts their hands on you
so when i was started kickboxing and in
my mind i'm like i'm [ __ ] tight okay
yeah like how many weeks have you been
doing i'm talking about when i thought i
was tight yeah that was day one
he said how many hours he was the first
round he's like yeah
and then i remember all i needed was
some mitts there's this video that i
recorded of myself and i put it up and i
remember
right before i posted it up i'm like yo
why is this [ __ ] in slow motion though
like i'm not
i'm way faster than this yeah but it
puts in perspective how cocky people are
about their skills and specifically when
it comes to fighting right
fighting probably the worst because you
gotta have confidence yeah and i also
found out too when i
when i started training more often
there's people who have trained long
but they're also people who have trained
long and they suck yes i didn't know
this right so a lot of people would talk
big and i'm sitting here just absorbing
all these stories
but the thing about fighting that i
found out too which is awesome is
because it's such an honest sport you
could talk as much as you want
when you're on that mat it doesn't
[ __ ] matter it's the same as stand up
oh you're running
oh he sucks or this this like is the
crowd laughing like yeah there's no
it's very black and white yeah very
black it's super honest
so so sports and that it fighting has
this weird because everyone's been in a
fight so everyone thinks they can do it
yeah but you don't hear
anybody like now your boy's like dude i
would [ __ ] lebron up man
you'd like no one talks like no one says
like right and i would cross kyrie up so
[ __ ] bad
no fighting
people i hear it all the time dog if i
just get in there with floyd man one
[ __ ] [ __ ] that's all i need is one
bro
you ain't gonna do [ __ ] and it's uh
i think for me because i was trained for
like six years i was in the ufc
and they brought in the denver broncos
wanted to train with me and shane carwin
who was the heavyweight champion at the
time and i was like ranked like number
11 or 10 in the world
so the broncos came in you're talking
diesel d lyman's
linebackers and they you you heard them
before like man these guys ain't [ __ ]
they they might know the technique bob
[ __ ] toss them
like this oh really no [ __ ] clue
we get in there and they got rolled up
so [ __ ] fast they don't have that
then they were just like oh my god i'm
like and you guys
are at this level think of average joe
they think they can do the same [ __ ]
and you guys are the 0.01 percent of the
population and you
think like this like we had no idea i'm
like yeah [ __ ]
the like the i if the fight iq part is
crazy right the the the part where you
had to be very repetitious
in drills and sparring and then your
fight iq goes up without you even
noticing it i think like the
the hard part about kickboxing for me
was there's no belt system so you don't
know
until you get hit in the face about how
how great you are like your fight iq
just starts to level up as you continue
to do this repetition
and so like i remember when i first
sparred like uh i didn't realize that i
flinched a lot
that's the first thing that people do
like you just when you play natural
yeah one of these right natural and i
just couldn't it was frustrating because
i couldn't figure out how not to do it
and it was just to get punched in the
face more
yeah and then it's the only way you use
that yeah you just it's like oh you
didn't die yeah
and so you start to get over it here and
there you know and i actually remember
when uh me and my buddy adam were
watching a specific ufc fight
and i [ __ ] hated you you know why wow
you knocked out my hero
crow cobb yep but here's my thing with
that he was my hero
i hated myself i dude i apologize to him
in the back
really oh yeah i was like dude i'm so
sorry and he
he's and i he's still my favorite
fighter of all time
he's the reason why i got the sport
because me and him went attitude
and he broke my nose and then it was a
good fight it was a great fight and i
got a knockout bonus
and then i'm looking at him he's this
[ __ ] walking
legend dude legend and he's so
[ __ ] up and he like doesn't know where
he's at he has his weird fanny pack on
i'm all [ __ ] up and i just look at him
i go dude
there has to be more to life than this
man like what are we doing
i was like i love you man i just [ __ ]
starched you out there
then this is for money i'm like this is
stupid
and he just looks at me with his broken
english goes this is life
and i was like it's not though dude this
ain't for me that's when i was like this
isn't for me
oh you thought about that that early on
and you still continue to fight as soon
as after
as soon as that fight ended i looked at
my team i'm like i don't want to do this
man
do you think that that fight was the
reason why like your your
your your fight record got a little
splotchy because you didn't feel it
right here because i don't think
i mean in my personal opinion right
anybody that's a heavyweight in like
you're top ten
if you're a top 10 heavyweight fighter
in my personal opinion just from you
know i've seen you since i was a kid
i feel like top 10 everybody has it it's
a mentality point at that you're 100
okay yeah but um
the thing that with me i was almost like
a cheat code in a video game where
i didn't have the experience or the
skills but i was playing at the hardest
level so i got by them athleticism but i
have the experience
so i got to a certain level even that
cro cop fight was a war man
yeah real realistic guy i probably
should take him out earlier than that
but it was a war because he's a [ __ ]
savvy vet
he's seen a big athletic kid so then you
get so i i beat gonzaga
before him i started in three rounds and
gonzaga [ __ ] star
yeah i beat the [ __ ] out of gonzaga so
he's ranked like 11. so i start gonzaga
put on a boxing clinic i'm like oh [ __ ]
that's cool then i get crow cop i'm like
holy [ __ ] my hero starch him
and then again it's this cheat code
where i got basically i got thrown to
the main event right away and i wasn't
made
a main event experience and then i
started fighting nogueras and rothwells
and
these monsters who were like oh big
athletic kid with a heavy right hand
cool
we've seen this before and then i just
wasn't ready for the moment
so then it was and then also my heart's
not fully into it
and i feel bad like my number one thing
with my coaches i saw with my coach the
other day about this
he's like man if you just had a mean
streak you'd been world champion
he was like you're always too nice to
everybody you're always too nice man in
the gym you're too nice
i was like i don't want to hurt people
dude it's not worth it to me like i'd
rather do other [ __ ] man
the same way that's so interesting the
same way yeah
explain yourself please is that where it
stops
the same way but hey then the light is
which is a huge fight for me and he went
on to do great things
i submitted him in the first round first
anaconda choke ever by heavyweight
first round choke he was my friend man i
cared about matt
so like he was like oh let's talk [ __ ]
to each other and i'm like i don't want
to do this dude i care about you
he's like oh this is what we got to do
i'm like this sucks dude because there
were elephants in the circus
because i never understood like even now
from an outside perspective where
people will go to war they'll literally
bash your [ __ ] face in
and then they're hugging after i'm like
don't dude touch me you
you try to kill me you know but it's
kind of like
uh with comics like if you're a torn
comic like you know that road work grind
so when you see each other in an
airport even if you don't know each
other but you're familiar with each
other
you bond because you've gone through the
same [ __ ]
so it's like you know guys that serve in
war together they have this bond that's
unbreakable so like
my last fight when i fought travis brown
he [ __ ] hated me i used to date his
ex-girlfriend he hated me his team hated
me
after the fight he came in my locker was
like you're right man because you have
that weird like
we both went through awful [ __ ] and we
and we got it done
and you know and then there's there's
this weird respect
got it yeah it's it's how do you how
would you like handle
like for example right um because i
follow you
you have some of the most worst comments
that i've ever read in my life for a
very successful platform right
um and i always found this very odd is
when people question your fight iq even
though you've been a top 10 heavyweight
and they want to tell you how fight
works right yeah sure is that annoying
for you
i don't see it dude because it annoys me
you know
but that's what i signed up for like
it's like on the platforms i'm on
the voice that i have of course you can
get backlash like if you go to drake and
i'm not saying i'm at their level but if
you go to drake's comments or kevin
hart's
lebrons they're getting hate but they're
not hate on me because i'm not
successful
you know what i'm saying like if i
wasn't doing [ __ ] they wouldn't be
hating
my level of success brings that and i'm
not even know where the hates only
get worse cause i'm just getting started
yeah i'm launching thick boys studios in
june like i have so much [ __ ] going on
and even bigger announcements like oh if
you guys are hating on this
geez man wait tc what i do so it's just
good
and i don't see i don't see any of it
dude i look at my bank account i make
sure my family's right
and i look at my uh touring ticket sales
as i don't look at numbers for podcasts
i look at nothing
that's smart and then i look at my bank
up see how my ads are doing everything
good good good
cool man i don't see social media dude i
don't see any of it
i post i get out yeah yeah yeah i think
that's just
good like your heroes growing up didn't
have social media like can you imagine
if richard pryor had social media
or if michael jordan did or if michael's
doing a daily podcast they could be a
nightmare
i'll be interested in your comments be a
nightmare it's it's i feel i feel bad
for kids though you know
i do too this is the world that they
grow up in and uh i was talking to my
friend uh her kid
is a sophomore in high school and she
was telling me that kids now
your popularity isn't based on what you
do in school is what you do outside of
school isn't that a bummer
so it's based on your social media
following are you serious that's why i
was a fan when they were gonna get rid
of
followers so people can see i'm like oh
that's so great for the youth but then
they didn't
they didn't do it because but also back
to the haters dude i've
never ever in my life ever out of all
the hate that i get
i've never had someone doing better than
me hate on me ever in my life
in that whole that's really smart isn't
that weird never i never i've never had
bill burr talk [ __ ] to me joe rogan no
let me go delete all my comments and i'm
just talking
about people i'm like [ __ ] you [ __ ] ass
mother [ __ ] ass [ __ ] ass
[ __ ] but you're not gonna punch
down
you know you're not gonna like find some
random dude and talk [ __ ] it's just
if you're doing something yeah you just
just come to the territory
i tell these guys all the time dude
social media is not real man that's not
the real world
people have polarizing comments on there
and they're trying to get attention
so they post the most wild [ __ ] i see
any of those people in the street
oh let me get a picture man let me do
this yeah yeah um the thick boy merch oh
it sucks yeah i sell out every time and
you have it on
yeah i i feel like for me too mentality
wise i started to understand that when
because when i was younger
everybody used to love dane cook right i
hated his stand-up
and what i used to say which was false
was like oh he's not funny he's like
well he if he's not funny how the [ __ ]
is he selling out madison square garden
yeah so what the [ __ ] am i saying right
it's like he cannot be funny to me but
he's still funny though dude
dane's a beast yeah and there's a lot of
comics especially in my circle who hate
dane cook
really i came in after and dane's always
been [ __ ] great to me man so i stick
up for him he's a [ __ ]
he's so talented dude you'll hear
patrice talk about this
bill bird talked about this rogan talked
about this when they all came up in
boston yeah there was the [ __ ] hub
and no one wanted to follow dan cook
the [ __ ] he was doing dude monster
i dude i've seen him do just there's
there's these two
uh basic strippers at the common store
in the main room and dane was on
and every comic went into the background
like those [ __ ] girls man in the
front that's what
season comics every comic i went on
they're loud during my seven like
i just powered through it ignored them
they're so loud they're disrupting
everything
and as i go off uh i have to bring on
dane
and uh dangerous which ones are they and
he picks it up it's this [ __ ] two
right there he goes
cool oh [ __ ] dude he goes out there and
he just starts
doing his thing they go beep
dude for 30 minutes straight with some
of the best material you've ever heard
off the top of the dome
he lit them up so bad they walked out
the whole crowd stands up
clapping damn i was like that's not
gonna make it professional doug
professional i mean you went from from
finding the stand-up i mean i don't even
know how that happens
oh i've always wanted to do stand-up and
my way into it was meeting brian count
getting
and then doing pot of comedy podcasts so
me and brian would do
live firing the kids but it wasn't a
live podcast suck dude
brian's doing now but whatever um
shout out to big and hungry i love you
guys but live podcasts are a disaster
but me and brian used to do it
but it was a performance so brian i'd be
like dude i'm not doing live podcast
i've seen those are so boring he's like
no dude
we're going to use our fan base and then
every show we start with you're going to
do 10 minutes
yeah you're going to start every show
with 10 minutes so that's how you
understand that that's
that's when i met you guys yeah that uh
you stand up live yeah you guys were
doing the live podcast
is there a lot of pressure i mean even
for all you guys like for example
uh because you've been put on by joe
rogan on a lot of these great comics
right yeah
and like i said like i know of your work
i know what you do i know what people
say yeah so is there a lot of pressure
for
for you to do better than what people
expect out of you because a lot of
people feel that
you've been kind of put on a platform
because a lot of people have pushed you
up there
to be at a certain place because i feel
like that's a lot of pressure right
i don't feel the pressure i feel like uh
so
rogan delia brian theo
uh joey santino bobby lee you can go
through the entire whitney cummings the
entire list of these monster comics
they're not going to cosign if i wasn't
funny i'm not going to sell every show
on the road
multiple times in multiple cities year
after year if i wasn't funny
so again that that online chatter is not
real dude
it's not really about what happens on
the stage in the crowd that you do again
ticket sales
podcast views you know bank account
that's all real i can
i can see that in black and white i
don't care about anything else i feel no
pressure
i feel no pressure you have a very
strong mentality why do you not do you
not feel that
you would you you would have to what
else am i yeah what am i going to do
what else would you do
that's true what are we going to listen
to them yeah yeah yeah
but if they knew what they were doing
they would do it
a hundred percent yeah oh his sp
whatever oh his special sucks let me see
your special
bam oh you don't have one no man cause
all right you're out if you have a
special i'll listen to you if you're a
legit comic toy comic like i am
if you sell more takes to me i'll listen
to you so how did you feel about the
critique about your special then
like uh from don't see it damn man
you're
man you got the blinders on son that's
good man i don't see it
but you're coming with the questions
today
no i love it because yeah but the as far
as special so
it depends like i i probably too early
to do it probably two you know only two
years in stamp doing special is crazy
because because for me too right because
i i became a fan i was watching you
on the podcast scene right sure so when
i saw you do the special i also felt it
was a little too early for you you know
because early for sure yeah because you
know two years in that's mad fast
you know so when here here's my question
for you in the haters to say this
what would you do if every outlet name
name a show
offered you a special and a half an hour
what would you do
you're gonna not do it what are you
gonna do and then listen
so no yeah you don't know me like that
no no
no don't be like that big [ __ ] bro and
then and then that
special parlayed into every other thing
i do with show time which i have a
multi-year deal with
and then okay and then yeah yeah so yeah
so the haters
didn't it didn't hurt you so it's like
hey what put that dick on this table
real quick right now
so but then also after that like now i
have pressure
i have offers from any big company you
know to shoot another special that's
awesome
so that's everybody when we do
you know what i'm saying so it's like i
don't know what we do damn yeah
you're a wise sage yeah i mean you kind
of have to be to
go through all that because i i think
it's interesting as well like
the amount of just like [ __ ] hate is
just like
it doesn't make sense because i go like
we go on the road with you and the shows
are sold out and people are
[ __ ] ecstatic to like like they're
excited to see you but when you think
about hate
you probably again they're the loudest
in the room yeah so it's 300 losers who
are in their mom's basement
oh this guy ain't [ __ ] watch those guys
[ __ ] i bet you would trade your life
with me
you know what i'm saying oh a hundred
percent yeah yeah yeah yeah oh one 100
percent
if you're like any of them if any of
them and then
so then the the critique of oh he's just
he's just where he's at because rogan
put him on you know many people rogan's
put on
you know how many people yeah how many
how many people has rogan put on
i can give you a [ __ ] plethora
of [ __ ] people and they ain't doing
[ __ ] but you also had to work hard for
that sellout because i remember when we
had steve
on he was saying too like he was like
yeah my name i'm stevo but he goes i
wasn't selling out shows immediately
like
it just doesn't work that way like how
many doesn't work how many doesn't work
yeah
it doesn't work that way like you have
to work your ass off to be
a ticket sale the improv the laugh
factory the ice house
comic works in denver it's not going to
pass me because i was a good ufc fighter
the comedy store like let me go on the
main room and the belly room because i
was a good ufc fighter
it doesn't work that way it's just
comedy doesn't work that way
that's true i mean it kind of goes back
to that conversation about like how
honest
that that specific industry is right
like when you go on stage
if you're not funny nobody's gonna
[ __ ] laugh no one's gonna laugh no
one's gonna show up
i couldn't follow joey diaz or theo or
brian or joe
the comments don't allow it happen
there's no way
yeah they don't they don't give a [ __ ]
dude yeah
it was it was interesting though because
i like i've never seen somebody go from
that to this
you know from fighting into this right
no one has just because like when i when
you typically hear fighters on a mic
it's like
move on please
you know why because they were born to
do that yeah i wasn't dude
i i was i had a lack of options and no
other choice and
it was like i'll try this out next time
i'm an ultimate fighter
all right guess i'm doing this you know
you have like ben rothwell on the mic
just
doing his lap i'm like you're gonna be
you could be a stand-up comic here
you maybe you could do it peace man yeah
no no one has but now there's a
hopefully it encourages a lot of these
fighters or other athletes
to like dude there's so much more after
your sport like you're
young man when you retire you guys have
so much you can do
well that's why you have fighters like
crow cop who just fight until their body
breaks down
and you know there's a there's a friend
of mine he has like heavy cte right
really every time he speaks i'm just
like i don't know what the [ __ ] is did
he have a lot of fights or experience
a lot of fights you actually know him
but he uh or you know of him but he's
a lot of head damage right uh say his
name was edited out
oh yeah yeah he has it bad he has it bad
you know and for me
uh growing up i used to watch him all
the time and so to watch him go through
that and see his speech fall apart
and at the same time he doesn't know
anything else besides fighting
fight or die that's the skill set and so
it's like for me i i wish somebody would
have had a conversation with them and
say hey
this is way more important than
everything else like you're [ __ ] this
[ __ ] up like ct is serious
it's a short short-lived career too
probably five
i don't know five or six years yeah
think how short of a time that is dude
five or six years yeah and then most of
these guys go on to
i don't know teach kickboxing in the ufc
gym like that's not a life dude
yeah it's just not you know the juice
isn't worth the squeeze because it's
like what
once you identify with this one specific
thing and because like you said it's
such a short career
the thought of what comes after people
don't really think about you but you
can't
because if you're in pursuit of that
title dude you can't be thinking about
anything
else anything else i could see that yeah
yeah
yeah i don't know man like it's just
been weird like being able to to be
around fighters and see what they go
through
like 99 of the population is not about
that life
no 99 it's it's cool to say it on the
outside low i would have done this i
would have done that
no you [ __ ] wouldn't it's about i
would i would never say that
i'm terrible it's a beast man and also
they're
99 of them aren't compensated well for
it so it's not like
you know you see you know whoever it is
not not conor mcgregor fight
it's not like they're set for the year
man they're literally fighting to feed
their family
they need those fights yeah yeah dude
and no benefits nothing
see i see i don't know about the pay
structure about fighting too i do
okay so you weren't getting paid jack
[ __ ] when you were fighting like miracle
crocodile
no because i and i especially got [ __ ]
because i was on the ultimate fighter
contract the ultimate fighter
it's basically like if you want american
idol so if you win american island you
carry underwood and you sell
10 million you know albums
you're not getting that money american
idol is going we put you on dude
so we're taking 90 you get 10. so for
the ultimate fighter they're going we
put you on
so not only no matter what you do in the
ultimate fighter you made to the finale
cool this is your contract
your first fight you get eight and eight
after you get 10 and 10 12 and 12 14
and 14 and 16 and 16. so when i fought
merkel crow cop i got 14 and 14.
he made over a million dollars which
rightfully so he should legend
before 28 grand dude after taxes and
paying my gym i
might have walked out with 12 grand
after beating cro cop
when i went twelve thousand dollars to
get into a fight like that that [ __ ] was
nuts
horrible i'd have reconstructive nose
surgery like it was the nightmare man i
still have scar tissue in my eye
like of course got ct from that fight
and then after that i fight no guerra in
brazil cool brendan go down to brazil
get knocked up by nogara and we're gonna
give you 16 grand
and then you're gonna get taxed in
brazil and north america
no see a lot of people don't know this
[ __ ] dude that's crazy to me because i
can't imagine getting stocked in the
face for pennies
you know i want floyd mayweather money
you know but
is that same with boxing too yes but
that's the problem is there's floyd
there's connor
there's rhonda there's brock lesnar
there's these guys that you see
and like oh no the [ __ ] because they're
the most famous like oh those guys
getting paid
it's like yeah the rest of the card is
getting by man
they're driving [ __ ] civics and you
know just trying to make ends meet
working other jobs a lot of trying to
work that
your heavyweight champion stipe is a
firefighter
shane caron when he beat frank mayer was
the heavyweight champion of the world he
was a
uh he was a water engineer for the city
of greeley what
wait how is stipe still is he an active
firefighter
how is he working and training to be i
think he's part-time but he's still but
that's his job doug
that's what he does he's a firefighter
he's a badass see i can't handle all
this stuff man fighting enough it's
heartbreaking man fighting is such a
crazy thing dude just have somebody
punch you in the face like i remember
just getting socked in the face full
force i'm like this ain't me i'm like
i ain't about i don't want my kids to do
it but it's the same it's similar to
like you know you look at special forces
guys obviously there's jocko's and
there's tim kennedy's of the world or
david goggins
there's a shitload of other special
force guys who have a specific
set of skills man and when they get done
they can't go on those tours anymore for
whatever reason their bodies build up
what do they do yeah they get done the
military's like thanks for your service
see ya
and they're in the real world like what
the [ __ ] do i do man yeah yeah that goes
ptsd or it's depression
because they've had a uh objective to
defend america and
kill bad guys and have these dope
operations and this special op [ __ ] and
these dope watches and they're flying
helicopters then you want them to work
at an insurance company
of course they're not doing well man so
you have no inclination to ever want to
do an exhibition match or anything else
never
if you ever see me in a celebrity boxing
match
jake paul easy on the celebrity though
but
i'm not i'm not a celebrity i don't know
if you ever see me in that things aren't
going well
that means i have no other offers to do
a special that means i looked at my
numbers and they're not doing well yeah
hey brendon versus lamar down on me
and i am dancing with the stars yeah i
wanna dance with the stars
yeah i mean you were you boxed for like
what 13 years right
were you trying to go professionally
yeah bro i went professional i was up at
floyd mayweather camp and uh
did you actually fight pro yeah but then
i got hurt b
let me just tell you it's now it's my
sad story so
it's not being the oldest the old uncle
rica man dude
[Applause]
you know i look at these sean porters
and earl spence i'm like
that could have been me do you think so
yeah i believe i i i've seen him
no absolutely
but here's the problem sean porter
is a multi-time world champion i love
you you're telling dick jokes with me
yeah so he so what you what you did my
response
what you did to him when it didn't count
yeah doesn't matter you're right because
what counts is when the lights are on
you're right
so that's like saying i'm the funniest
guy in the room yeah and then we go and
do a show this weekend in miami and you
ate dick
well you're not the funniest guy in the
room yeah because it matters yeah you
when the lights are on sean porter
counts when the lights are on
so during training in this young buck
maybe it went easy on you i don't know
but if you guys got an actual pro fight
and i love you listen this i want your
heads i love you
listen sean porter would [ __ ] you up
right now because i'm
right now oh [ __ ] he's got hands
i got his i believe it i don't see belle
he has hands to you
in your world
have you ever seen lomo chanko throw
punches or hit mitts you have seen
cannon
pull up this woman
i don't know who's willing
my god these guys are [ __ ] good and
then you go to a kevin hart show like
holy [ __ ] those guys suck yeah
it's a different level yeah you're right
i want to hear your story though so yeah
yeah thank you bro
you've been world champions compliments
you go hold on you shut the [ __ ] up
i want to be very clear this level's
good
let me clarify you are here
in my store yeah here
oh
he's like i'm glad you brought this up
man for me it started at the age of 11.
i knew my hammock was gonna give out
just a matter of time
i know i was gonna be a fighter because
my mom had me premature so i was
fighting in the womb
so what happened with your boss it was
some street stuff so uh
we was in floyd mayweather's and the guy
name is uh
memphis we call him memphis and we were
fighting
and in the boxing ring and floyd
mayweather okay and mayweather jim
mayweather mayweather's there we filming
it
and uh cause it's like was talking [ __ ]
it's just some street [ __ ] and i was
getting the better of him
and he lifted me up and i never wanted
to fall on the mat i lift me up
and when i try to catch myself in my leg
right
so i'm like man you [ __ ] so it was like
stuff yeah so i tried to train on it
okay all right boom leg while i was
running
fell out okay boom had to get surgery
what kind of
detour acl right here on my knee okay
all right mcm yeah people athletes do it
all the time and come back
keep going again
i'm just you're talking come on
[Applause]
[Applause]
so boom say like bro you're going to be
in the hospital you know me
off for like four three four months like
whatever you know i'm young rehab
yeah i'm young how old are you at this
time i'm uh
17. okay 17. super young super young bro
you know that's not back like
yeah sure so easy surgery so boom i'm
month and i'm on crunches already
doing my thing i'm like oh i feel good
i'm about to trade again
right dad said no coach said no i'm like
whatever i'm gonna just start running so
i started running
killing it talk about three months
please i'm athlete right
i started tr two months and started
training again
cool i started sparring in three months
right
three months after the surgery yeah yeah
that's a bad idea and then i [ __ ] i
was jumping rope feeling good and i felt
bad that day but i was like man
you know you floyd you talk [ __ ] talking
[ __ ] again
try to get my get back all right go in
there from round one
go out there and i did a spin move out
there again it was like malik you a
[ __ ]
and then you just stopped after that
yeah my mom was like yes enough so she
put me in a west la college
this reminds me of booby miles for
friday night lights me and him are
similar
that was like oh yeah that was a true
story you see friday night lights uh
no i'm familiar with the story though oh
yeah but again that's just so that was
me but that's why i get so much respect
because i tried to train
and i was uh injured and flo was like do
you do you regret doing that
hell yeah all right well not really not
really not really
yeah not really because now look you
like where you're at now oh yeah i love
you
right now but again to his point like
all my friends like
i i saw tank you know i'm cool with tank
broner and all them they
all climbed and all that stuff like damn
they making millions
yeah but then just i mean just the fact
that broner has his issues exactly and
then the fact that like now you just
like where do you go out the box and i'm
starting to see like brown and he fell
off
well how did he how did you transition
from boxing into comedy then uh
i went to that's a great question so i
was in theater after uh
i got hit injured i went to uh college
juco you know
masters in communications
steal it without saying a word i want to
see a degree
it's there somewhere i dropped out
without thinking what he said
this [ __ ] i dropped out i
dropped out
thought you went to long beach state
northridge
yeah i did always question me man
why you always why y'all squished me man
you know i went to school
that's so funny dude oh we have a mascot
back there we got one now
at least at least whatever you decided
to do it led your hair right there oh
yeah no matter what
i was in creed and i started boxing
again and uh michael b jordan was in the
gym
and i was training and he was like hey
bro you uh you box i was like yeah and
he came with a childhood friend named
corey cowellette
and he was like hey bruce dude it's bad
you should put him in the movie
oh he was like you ever did acting i was
like yeah the acting so audition
i do a little something yeah i went in
there i was like bro this the role you
want i'ma embody that
and i did that and uh that led to
another film called netflix bernie sands
killed it
oh yeah you did yeah and then i was a
comedy relief and i was like bro you
should do stand up so i took a class and
then i just started hitting a lot of
open minds you took a stand-up class
yeah
live factory or what no i did the david
david
uh who's with friends with uh gary owen
okay my heart so does michael b jordan
actually got hands
is he good no no he's all right he just
wanted to make sure he's just acting
like he says no no no creep three coming
out yeah you got hands
that boy bodied up for creek three yeah
you see me
because you said that you wanted to do
an exhibition match with uh roy jones jr
you know i was like you are out of your
[ __ ] mind that's one of you jordan
said that michael b jordan said that i
was like are you out your [ __ ] mind
he would body you
kill him yeah destroy him yeah at any
age he'll just yeah
that's like your confidence after that
day he's like yeah yeah yeah yeah you
can destroy michael b
jordan yeah yeah better be able to yeah
hey
uh go to current events go the one i
sent you cap because this shows you
this high school this is off world star
shout out to the world star this high
school kid was talking
[ __ ] was talking [ __ ] to the white mamba
they doing this thing
[ __ ] and he goes put your shoes on the
line and because
have you ever played with the nba guy uh
my buddy khalif was
pro ball but not with the nba guy so
like chris anderson the birdman remember
he's on miami
championship teams he was big in denver
he's my boy chris anderson my boy okay
i just you know you see him dunking all
the time getting rebounds like that
this full can't shoot so we were at
greenwood athletic center and these kids
were talking [ __ ] to him he's like
cool we'll play three on three i'll have
brendan and like some dude off the bench
some fat white guy
he's like so it'd be us three for shoot
three three black guys they're like
talking [ __ ] to him like all he can do
is dunk he's like
i won't dunk at all you don't have to
worry about i won't dunk dude when i
tell you and he's not known as a
three-point shooter
he didn't he was like winner he's like
uh make it take it
we'll go to 11. dude when i say he
didn't miss a shot
he it was like steph curry he didn't
miss a [ __ ]
shot eleven in a row swap swag damn who
was there
these these black dudes big black dude
damn yeah but that's what i'm saying
you don't realize how talented nba
players are do you get around them
people don't know the the level and the
degree yeah yes because even with
basketball so my buddy khalif he played
pro internationally
and just playing like a pickup game like
21 with him not
it's different i'm like oh i can't do
[ __ ] if he if he
if i made a shot he's because he allowed
me to make it yeah i'm like oh there's a
there's a difference in this yeah it's
like when you roll with a
really good like a competitive black
belt like oh [ __ ] i'm not real
i'm not a real black belt like i got
ruled the [ __ ]
certain guys it's just what they do like
but bushes when i rode with him it's
like oh my god
it's like a different language like he's
i'm i'm not doing it right
but that's literally that's that's his
language but so these basketball players
like i know you play
and you play every sunday at the ymca
and you're the main star of the ymca
league
this guy that's his that's his language
dude you're playing his game
yeah so and you know he was solid in big
players not all-star
look what he does this kid and by the
way he's been out of the league for
what nba school years and a high school
player calls out nba
easy on the legend of nba yeah
brian scala scallop breen scott
excalibur white mambas what they call
him
so he's just he's just there shooting
around look
he said put your shoes on
he got that high-waisted pants too you
know he look at him
look at him dude he rode the bench for
the celtics like he beats him 11 tonight
get the [ __ ] out of here
they wasn't backing down though oh why
you jumping oh
good block look 11 nothing
did he hit him with the this quarter is
over damn
well that's the thing though it did for
these kids to see that yeah there was a
high school kid that was talking mad
[ __ ] to john wall back in the day oh
yeah remember that he passed away
damn i was about to talk [ __ ] recipes
dude bro yeah you know but he bodied uh
john wall that was going back and forth
yeah but you know nah but you know he
was he was you ever seen dwyane wade and
his son
his son's like talking [ __ ] and he's
like you really want to play and then
have you seen it he weighed by himself
he knocks him down
and his son gets pissed he's like all
you can do is buy me down because you're
so big yeah and he was like
and then he was like cool and then he
just started shooting through questions
but
to your point that guy was about to be
like the next guy up
he was good he was right he passed away
was it like a medical condition he got
shot
yeah but uh pull out that video channel
which one do you uh when dwight uh john
john wall and the high school kid
he passed away that it's like that high
school kid talking [ __ ] to cam newton
at his camp what the [ __ ] have you seen
that what are you thinking dude this is
right here
they were balling he was the next step
or two yeah this is when he was
like fresh out of uh he was playing for
washington you cannot though
is that that kid you had something like
[ __ ] the blessing yeah there you go
oh that's right
you ain't having it that's embarrassing
yeah
put his shoes on he was nice i leave my
shoes time
kobe's show john how to play ball
damn do you want to play me check
[ __ ]
i don't think he's in high school though
yeah yeah he's a he's a high schooler
he's like high school he was nice no
it's in a high school i don't think that
players
yeah he was uh scroll down to the
comments you don't have
neck fat like that in high school yeah i
was looking at that too i'm like oh man
rp big man uh what's his name though
tyrique yeah tyree tyree uh you can go
type him in he was like next up
he was next up uh in high school i think
he i forget what
number he was ranked but again i know i
know what you were talking about though
bro
but he died from a heart condition he's
a large heart oh sorry
also it was a medical condition okay oh
he wasn't he's way less sad than
getting shot but it's still sad yeah he
died my bad someone told me
three start recruit from oklahoma state
three star
three now no three star it's three star
um
that's that's kind of that's not good i
mean obviously you've got a full right
of
oklahoma state so it must be a beast all
right yeah but i knew she was talking
what else you got jenny cat
yeah okay
i love seeing that white mama just okay
so
uh recently people are giving we're
giving kylie jenner [ __ ] because she
posted a gofundme link on her instagram
story
a makeup artist that she worked with in
the past got into a terrible car
accident
his family was trying to raise money for
his medical costs
and according to her they originally
started with a
ten thousand dollar goal when she saw
the gofundme it was at six thousand
already so she donated five thousand
and what she ended up doing was posting
that link onto her
instagram and the family saw that they
were getting more money and they raised
the uh goal to 60 000. so when people
saw it they were like oh why is kylie
jenner only giving 5 000 when the goal
is 60 000. she can donate that easily
and people giving her [ __ ] for what she
wants to do with her money for helping
out her friend
yeah for helping out her friend and
people were saying that uh she should
pay for the whole
uh procedure because it was her employee
but he had done her makeup here and
there six years ago
so it's kind of like a friend of a
friend yeah i really don't really know
he's in time of help yeah but she wanted
to help she already surpassed
the original goal but it was shared
exactly people were giving her a hard
time because they were saying that
her her circle are all filled with
millionaires and that they could take
care of that cost why ask your fans who
are in
middle class usually well they don't
even know what if that person was like i
don't want you to pay for it yeah
there's a lot of different
they wanted her they want her to pay for
it at all and not just give her five
grand she's like
you're a billionaire why can't why are
you speculating what somebody else
should do with their money
like we're the weirdest [ __ ] people i
sort of well not us the people that
said this yeah this and this is twitter
yeah and it's twitter it's instagram
it's kind of
in my opinion it's the younger like
social justice warrior type of people
they started using lady gaga as a
reference saying that she paid all of
the medical bills for her dog
walker who got [ __ ] and shot defending
the dogs and that's her best friend a
little different
she had talked to this dude in six years
yeah so a lot of people are just giving
her [ __ ] and then they started
to go down the line of like oh well she
pays for this private jet that would
have costed sixty thousand she makes
this much
in an hour it would have covered the car
it's just a bunch of people being mad
about her trying to share gofundme
we call them dummies right now let's
jump these hoes and it went so bad
i'll tell you someone who probably don't
pay attention to social media would be
the kardashians
there's no way they're too infamous well
they but also they probably don't even
run there they teflon yeah
i bet they have access to theirs but i
bet they they have a whole team they
have a whole team look at this like
you know what smith i know will smith
doesn't it at all he and the artist's
face you know
derek used to post and used to work for
will smith really yeah because will
smith was like hey man i want to get
you know good on instagram i need help
so he had like a whole writing room and
they'd come up with ideas
and then he didn't have access to it he
just wanted to create dope content have
upload it so he'd stay relevant he's
somebody that knows how to do uh social
media really well he transitions so well
well
smith but that's what he's saying his
team he has his team a whole team behind
him
that's not fair i was like how's he
doing how's he come up with all these
great ideas well he's on like top of the
empire state building
doing the posters
yeah they're definitely levels to this
game yeah there are no it's weird
um okay so next do you remember who
topanga was from boy
oh my god i see her all the time she
loses my really she does she's here
all the time i'll be on my bike i'm like
damn
girl what's up
the transition was weird yeah it was
weird the reference was strange
so her husband was uh eating
a a bowl of cereal it was cinnamon toast
crunch and he found something weird in
the bag he
decided to pour it all out he saw that
there were crystallized
like sugar on shrimp tails there was a
string
and at the bottom of the bag you could
see these little like pellets
and people are speculating that was rat
[ __ ] yeah people thought that he was
faking it trying to get attention but
he's like you can see there are like
sugar crystals
on this shrimp tail and the little
pellets are actually attached to the
cereal like
scroll up jim what'd he say he goes okay
well after further investigation with my
eyes these are semi-coated shrimp tails
you weirdos
i was at all that mad until you now
tried to guess light me
because what ended up happening after he
posted it is that cinnamon toast crunch
on their
social media reached out to him and they
gave one of the worst like pr
apologies ever where they basically said
hi we're so sorry that you had like a
situation with one of our boxes however
there's definitely
zero percent chance that this was any
contamination without [ __ ] those are
shrimp tails
yeah and i bet they're delicious i was
just about to think i better eating
covered in that
really good cinnamon and sugar yeah i
thought that those are friends
they were trying to try some [ __ ] out
bro
dude we got all this access shrimp what
do you do
we went to the wrong house because he
came to my house so he posted this
saying that like it's definitely shrimp
you guys are trying to gaslight me they
responded back saying we're so sorry
that
you're having this experience we're
gonna go ahead and send you a box with
some shipping labels please send us the
shrimp
so we can further investigate ourselves
send them one
eat the rest for yourself that's what he
said he's like he's gonna you know
what's up yeah
that's [ __ ] ridiculous wait wait wait
wait
wait
wait
wait
wait
wait
wait
wait wait wait wait wait wait wait how about
toast crunch like our batman you know
what do we send you a free
i see it it's like i think they were
just trying to kind of cover their ass
like that's not accepting
any blame they're like oh it's so weird
why there should never have had been
trip tales in this absolutely not from
us but send it to us so we can make sure
oh shrimp tails but that's weird though
because a majority of i only know this
because of college but a majority of
like packaged food like this like dry
goods yeah they have a certain
amount of like rat feces trash and
garbage that's allowed to pass
and bugs and bugs that still allows it
to be edible so
of course it could be street tails so
why would they deny it
i'll still eat i'll still eat that box
of [ __ ] cereal oh bro
i got this new protein powder it's
fruity pebble flavor and they have cocoa
puff flavor
bro hit different huh put some shrimp
tails in that bit
pre-workout hitter i wonder what that
tastes like it looks pretty good bro
i can confidently i can completely say
that uh
cinnamon toast crunch is the best cereal
when you say it when you're sad yeah
they should go
deep yeah there's a struggle for you to
get that out but
yeah i can come it's a little stop yeah
i can 100
i'll tell you right now if i'm sad i'm
going for a cinnamon toast crunch
right before he left he whispered in my
ear i have to call pete
that's how you know chin's getting paid
was like man [ __ ] y'all get this [ __ ]
okay this is a sad one but kind of good
uh
this is not sad it's hilarious the
grandmother who got
beat in uh san francisco had a gofundme
account and they actually ended up
raising almost
a million dollars to help her with her
medical bills and everything she decided
to take all that money and donate it
to different causes to try to uh help
come back
that's what's up there that's love dude
she said she didn't watch
this dude up she fought back she fought
so this this
i don't know the exact story but the
story is is that this dude attacked her
that's why she's [ __ ] up but she
[ __ ] him up worse and this is what he
looked like when they were
getting him literally the attack damn
grandma [ __ ] him she was fighting back
punching him and [ __ ] i think she had
like an umbrella with her so she might
have like swung something but look at
him leave his dumbass
beat up on little asian people but we
fight back and she [ __ ] him up let me
see the asian lady
was she chinese uh yes chinese where's
this at
san francisco he got [ __ ] up look at
her she's still
[ __ ] cussing him out so who else
wants some oh she has that paddle
yeah around the globe so he did he so
did he try
robbing her is this the racial thing
where he's like trying to [ __ ] her up
just he's trying to [ __ ] her up wow
god damn yeah what a piece of [ __ ] man
beat his head now we know who you are
let's jump right into how stupid you got
to be to see an old elderly asian person
go i'm going to [ __ ] them up because of
what kovid you [ __ ] idiots
it's weird like i don't i don't
understand what like what's your
objective
like what so after you beat up this old
lady what have you done
what's the gameplay you know
unfortunately there's the same people
leaving comments
like well you know the guy had a point
you know like yeah yeah yeah yeah
did he flip her off at the end i think
he was apologizing
i'm so sorry with the wrong one
sure so dude good for that grandmother
i'm just always scared about what's
gonna happen when somebody [ __ ] with
the wrong person's grandmother
like it's it's like a lot of people may
or may not know this but there is a
lot of asian gangs like
the bay area especially in the bay area
specifically out in new york i'm not
talking about gang [ __ ] that gang [ __ ]
is petty [ __ ] i'm talking about mafia
yeah
yeah triad chinese mafia [ __ ] this
country has a huge history with like
drug trafficking and stuff that had to
deal with like chinese mafia we're
talking about like 200 years ago type of
[ __ ] and it's still here
they run [ __ ] so you're gonna [ __ ] with
the wrong person's grandmother
and then people are just gonna start
disappearing and i'm like okay i'm good
yeah my thing is good it's just weird
it drives me nuts that that that that
mass shooter in boulder
like oh he's apprehended he just got
shot in the leg it's like dude he should
be stoned to death
these [ __ ] mass shooters what if they
get apprehended all they do is
all right they get life in prison that's
not enough dude yeah gotta make an
example of these [ __ ] idiots
do you feel like covet is uh
exacerbating this [ __ ] because
everybody's at home and just losing
their [ __ ] mind well here's the
interesting thing about that with like
mass shooting and gun violence because
of the lockdowns gun violence is the
highest it's ever been
so people think oh like i heard
charlemagne drives me [ __ ] nuts
because i respect him and like him but
he's like oh we should we should stay
locked down if this is what's going to
happen mass shootings we should stay
locked down
it's like do some [ __ ] investigation
man breed some [ __ ] in your life
because gun violence and domestic
violence is through the roof
suicide is through the [ __ ] roof
because he's locked down oh i could see
when i was locked in that hotel for like
10 days right uh i was losing my [ __ ]
mind yeah man i'm
losing my [ __ ] mind like you know
people who
who are comics like we like to talk to
people we like to interact i
for five hours out the day i looked
outside the window and i just watched
people walk
because that was the closest thing i
could do that's all i could do i
literally watched people on the street
until the sun went away
it was it was so hard depressing i was
losing my [ __ ] mind
and like i just not being around people
not having human interaction makes me go
[ __ ] insane
i picked up biking over over quarantine
hell yeah just so i could you know
people wouldn't give me [ __ ] if i was
walking out
you know so i was like [ __ ] it if i'm on
a bike i'm doing cardio activity i could
not have a mask on yeah i could just
dodge people
yeah out their way so it's just like i i
did literally anything and everything i
could just to get
just to be outside yeah because i was
losing my mind i was going crazy now i
think if you're a kid
and your your your happiness comes from
friends stuff like that and you're
locked down so kids from
i think say five to 14 is the highest
rate of suicide that they've ever seen
damn five to four my five-year-old
wouldn't know how to [ __ ] tie the
rope
so when i hear five what the [ __ ] how do
these five-year-olds know how to kill
themselves that's what i'm saying i
don't know
youtube who knows that was a tutorial
for it
what else you got all right next one
madonna is accused of photoshopping
another woman onto her body and the
woman actually knows it's her body
madonna get younger of course someone's
like hey that's my [ __ ] body no
also that's pretty obvious so obvious
look at her head
no and apparently she didn't take it
down for a while that's the girl she
looks like the lady off
oh she looks like laid off mars attacks
was she just messing around no she put
on her instagram account
but then i looked at her instagram
recently and she took it off
i look cool rebel heart did she not
think the girl like obviously you're
super famous the girl like holy [ __ ]
that's a body and it looks like she
finally took it off
shows her [ __ ] the actual picture
she's been wilding she's been kind of
going a little
a little weird like a little crit people
just hate getting old in this city i
know like they just don't want to accept
the fact that you're going to get
they fight it you're going to get saggy
just let it [ __ ] happen
what's the problem they fight it like
with tooth and nails they [ __ ] fight
in hollywood they fight it man and then
they end up looking all weird and [ __ ]
with all the injections and [ __ ] like
come on they just chill off but then
sometimes they look pretty hot
now i don't like lip injections at all
man like i don't [ __ ] with that like if
you got lips you got lips and it looks
good
yeah yeah i'm gonna say the lip the lips
are a little a little much
yeah if they're done right though i
don't mind them
you're with the brazilian butt lift i'm
with you some titties
really you [ __ ] with the fake lips man
listen man
come on i wasn't
[Laughter]
better talk yeah all right that's it
yeah does david have any dates are you
doing any tours
i'm just podcasting right now all right
hello podcast this squad's in miami
thursday is almost sold out i think
there's ten tickets left
thursday two shows friday two show
saturday this [ __ ] week thursday
friday saturday
miami improv meet in the squad i'll be
there with chappelle
ricky cruz and uh my boy louise
i always forget his name diaz shout out
to louis diaz love you guys
um and then austin texas april 22nd
through the 24th
austin texas vulcan gas theater is in
austin texas right off 6th street
i think it's two shows thursday two
shows friday two shows saturday that's
in austin texas
get your tickets f-a-t-k-z dot-com but
miami is this week
my brother thank you for doing this man
yeah this was great you're a great man
with some hard-hitting questions yeah
man though the genius brain podcast you
guys have so much fun man
yeah i like watching your [ __ ] you guys
just have fun we just we just i didn't
even know what to do with the podcast at
first because everybody seemed so
focused on a subject i said whatever
[ __ ] it just talk and see what you stop
firing the kid like we have no agenda
here like if you came here like i want
to talk about just [ __ ] whatever
mma for the whole hour all right let's
do it
[Laughter]
appreciate it yeah genius brain genius
brain podcast on instagram
with david david so so thank you brother
we're out dude thank you sir
look at your picture who is that that's
him
that's him better ones that's hilarious
they come up cyberbullying
what's up man lacy yeah oh shout out to
manchester united you know what
chappelle has done the crow cop fans
look at the side of that
damn yeah how'd you know oh [ __ ] look at
that shout out to suplex
shout out to the flag ship what is it
no use looks like it
again yeezy because he's
the richest black man in america six
point six so i'm supporting him easy day
but i'm still kidding he's straight with
the ovo all right
david so i'll just talk about my kicks
okay
if you look down here these are the
olympic sevens if you have this this
should be a staple in your closet one of
my favorite jays of all time
with everything it goes with everything
i might had a cop awful guy i had those
when i was in middle school
yeah it was your favorite shoe yeah all
right let them know what you got okay
come on man in that corner wait wait for
this looking like this
ice cream though
it took me two hours to cut these bad
boys
miami this weekend let's go let's go
what up what up chinese up in the hazel
check out my
my shoes these are nike air max i don't
know the names really but i'm guessing
they're air masks because it said on the
side
shout out to suplex i think your name is
chris
hooking me up you the man aye
we out dope